(phone ringing)
- [Fan On Phone] Hello?
- Yo man, it's Gary Vaynerchuk!
- [Fan On Phone] What's going on, buddy?
- Life is good, you bro?
- [Fan On Phone] I'm good!
I watch you all the time.
You actually helped me get out
of a depression mode of mind.
Dude, I love you.
I'm inspired so much by you.
A lot of people say I'm a lot like you.
- I appreciate that, man.
That makes me really happy.
Anything I can answer for you?
- [Fan On Phone] Yeah, my
dad's having kidney failure
and I'm trying to find a
little bit of motivation
to keep on going with
this business he's having
and he kind of screwed it up a little bit.
I'm kind of lost on what to do.
I don't know if I should just go ahead
and start on my own
and let him see what he
can do by himself or what.
- Okay, let's break that down for a minute
because obviously that's intense
and there's a lot of emotion behind that.
Do you not know how to
operate the business?
If you're doing it out
of nobility and honor,
but you're not capable of running it,
obviously you don't want to put yourself
in that vulnerable spot.
Does that make sense?
- [Fan On Phone] Yeah, exactly.
I half-ass know how to run it.
- Understood, I appreciate
the authenticity.
Does he want you to do it?
Does he need it?
Give me one more layer of context
to see if I can give you any value.
- [Fan On Phone] He's
having kidney failure
and he wants me to take it over,
but at the same time,
he still wants to have
his thumb in control,
if you know what I mean.
- I see.
Of course I know what you mean.
Look, I think, for me, the
right answer in these moments
is for you to be overly...
It's such a complicated
conversation, right?
It's a really tough one,
but I think you've got to make a decision.
There's only two moves here.
You either go and have a
real conversation with him,
be like,
"Dad, I really want to roll this for you,
"but I need this autonomy,
otherwise it's half-pregnant,"
or you just eat the shit
and have the empathy
at the macro and just try to
navigate through that thumb,
given the circumstances.
- [Fan On Phone] Right, right, right.
- You know what I mean?
- [Fan On Phone] Yep,
I know what you mean.
I'm also trying to open up
my own business as well.
- What kind?
- [Fan On Phone] PDR business,
paintless dent removal.
I work for my dad and I do body work.
- I got it.
- [Fan On Phone] I'm trying
to do paintless dent removal,
and I'm getting ready to go to school here
in about six months.
- How old are you?
- [Fan On Phone] I'm 28.
- Got it.
I mean, look, you've got
your whole fucking life
in front of you.
I think 28's a tricky number,
'cause people get confused
'cause you're post that college era,
30 is looking you in the face.
I think there's an enormous
amount of confusion
in the system for 28-year-olds
about where they are in life.
- [Fan On Phone] Yeah,
that's my biggest problem
I've been having lately.
I've been watching a lot of you
and watching a lot of your videos
and a lot of things that you do
and all kinds of other stuff
and it's helped me kind
of come out and realize
my time is whenever I find
it, I got my own clock.
- [Fan On Phone] Bro, honestly, no joke,
I feel like you're closer to 2.8 years old
than the way you think about 28.
Like, you've got fuckin' 60
fuckin' years of execution
in front of you.
That's like two fucking full
lifes more of execution.
The problem with 28 is 28's
a fuckin' tricky thing.
28's fuckin' tricky.
28 is fucking too many people
up, because I'm telling you,
looking at 30, like,
"Wait a minute, shit 30 is here.
"Shouldn't I, quote-unquote,
have my life together?"
And then at 28, you got
five to 50% of your friends
that you went to high school
or college with that are
getting married, getting
somewhere in their life.
Don't let anybody else's fucking clock
dictate your game.
28 is early as fuck!
- [Fan On Phone] Yeah, it
used to bother me really bad
'cause they're all buying houses.
They're 25, 26 buying
houses and getting married,
having kids.
- Dude, that has...
Brother, brother!
Their fucking life have
nothing to do with you.
- [Fan On Phone] Well, after
I've watched so many videos
of yours, I snapped out
of it and realized that
my life is my life and
nobody can control it.
I'm going to be my own happiness.
Nobody else can control that.
- That's what's up, man.
And honestly, that makes me happy.
Honestly, I hope it's really sinking in
and it's not just early words
coming out of your mouth
because once you go there...
Dude, honestly, brother,
I'll shoot it fucking straight to you.
I'm 42 years old and I swear
on everything I've got,
I feel like I'm just starting
and everything that people think I am
and what I've accomplished and all that
is shit in my own head 'cause I'm like,
"I haven't even fuckin' started."
So imagine what I think about you at 28.
- [Fan On Phone] Yeah.
Dude, I've lost my girlfriend,
I couldn't tell you how many
friends I've thrown away.
I couldn't tell you how many friends
that I just stopped talking
to because they're losers,
they're not winners, they
don't have that ambition.
They don't have goals in life.
They have nothing.
- Listen, some of the most painful things
that so many people at 28 need
to do is cut out negativity
or people that are not
going to the next place.
Cutting out all that shit is enormously,
enormously impactful and
that makes me happy, man.
- [Fan On Phone] That's
what I've been doing.
- Just keep cutting
and if there's one
person that's happy left
then that's how you do
it, and if there's nobody,
fuckin' manifest it in
your own fuckin' dome.
Dude, 28 is the beginning.
- [Fan On Phone] Since I've
cut all that negative out,
I'm so much fuckin' happier.
So much happier.
- Brother, it makes me happy.
Thanks for calling, bro.
- [Fan On Phone] Thank you.